[Music]
blazblue persona 4 under night in birth
and Ruby for worlds that wonderfully
come together for a fast flashy and
endearing 2d tag fighter blaze blue
cross tag battle merges as an accessible
fighting game that breaks from the
series tradition by simplifying its
gameplay systems but by no means does
this make it shallow the dynamic tag
system and the clever ways you can mix
the game's unique mechanics our cross
tact shines here Arc System Works
unifies all franchises as a 5 button
fighter with two main attack buttons a
universal overhead attack that can also
function as an ax attack a tag button
and a partner skill while it may seem a
bit too straightforward even the most
historically complex characters on the
roster remain true to form where it
counts by distilling classic fighting
game mechanics the focus is shifted from
elaborate directional inputs to creating
openings for that suite high damage
combo especially once you factor in tag
assists and meter management you'll
recognize familiar moves with similar
properties from their respective games
but the conditions for execution have
changed basic attacks smart combos and
even super is called distortion skills
are easy to pull off
so the number of techniques mapped to
the limited controls can cause mistakes
particularly throws and distortion
skills auto forward - and most
characters may seem jarring to
fighting-game veterans but it doesn't
take that much effort to adjust to this
game's quirks and its pace partner
skills in particular will take time to
grasp every character has three unique
assist attacks where they fly in from
off-screen to lend a hand
cross combos take the tag system one
step further by letting your duo pylon
damage simultaneously
[Music]
these are the keys to executing great
combos creating openings or pulling
yourself out of a rut with this in mind
you're either encouraged to experiment
using different duo's or form your own
collaborative attacks with a pair that
you love most it's chaotic and sometimes
tough to nail down in live matches and
it's where the depth of the combat comes
from your effectiveness also revolves
around meter management the skill gauge
is used for distortion skills laying
down ax moves or saving up for
back-to-back supers with your tag
partner
the cross gage paves the way for cross
combos and tag counters and when you're
down a fighter the residents blaze kicks
you into overdrive by regenerating
health adding chip damage filling the
skill gauge and strengthening your
distortion skills
[Music]
Crosse tech battle has a lot to absorb
and it'll take time to get comfortable
with the fighting system and unravel all
of its intricacies thankfully the
onboarding process is top-notch tactics
mode walks you through the basic
terminology mechanics in their use cases
and each character has a tailor-made
tutorial that gives you the opportunity
to perfect specific combos and there's a
slew of missions in tactics mode that
pit you in difficult situations you'll
encounter in live matches all the pieces
of a fast smooth and endlessly fun
fighting game exists within cross tag
but it truly shines by channeling and
fusing the personality and charisma of
each franchise whether it's the stylish
super moves battle cries or fluid
animations this large cast is bursting
with charm
mixing up teams brings about
collaborations I've always wanted to see
happen
sure Ragna hide in Narukami may play
like the standard sword wielding boys
from their respective worlds but having
either them work together makes for a
badass team when I'm hopping from under
Knights Riverside stage one fight two
plays blues cathedral the next using my
favorite duo of Chie and Ruby while
listening to Hyde's battle theme cross
stack battle evokes and amplifies the
fondness I have for this roster and as a
diehard persona fan having the
investigation team reunited at Yasukuni
high for a hectic brawl while bumping
the arena mix to reach out to the truth
warms my heart especially smaller
moments like the unique chatter in
interactions between two characters
before fights commenced makes this feel
like more than a rehash of multiple
assets or a collection of characters
thrown together
[Music]
the crossing of worlds primarily plays
out in the episode mode the four
factions of Fighters are forced to
battle in a fake realm by a mysterious
omnipresent AI that creates arbitrary
rules yeah we are pleased to meet you
nice to meet you the overarching plot
sounds ridiculous and it's borderline
nonsensical each of the four campaigns
play out as a visual novel with static
character portraits and fully voiced
dialogue actual fights are embedded
within each chapter to keep you as an
active participant some character
appearances feel shoehorn for the sake
of making an appearance but despite its
absurdity moments of cross franchise
fanservice stick the landing
ruby's obsession with fancy weapons
permeates our encounters with the likes
of Ragna and hyde references the chi a's
obsession with steak and Yuki goes in
ability to make curry call back - when I
got to know them in persona 4 even Noel
gets caught up in the mix and she's
completely oblivious to how bad it'll
taste and as each episode concludes I
was rewarded with heartfelt scenes that
reminded me of why I love these
characters story mode also highlights
something odd DLC characters take part
in the story as opponents despite not
being available in the playable base
roster there movesets character models
theme songs and voice lines are in the
game but they're gated as add-on content
half of Ruby's cast is offered for free
but to see several persona BlazBlue and
under night folks
so obviously withheld feels unfair
[Music]
taking the fight online is where you'll
spend most of your time though cross
tags online component consists of
multiple lobbies for different skill
levels where players walk around as
chibi versions of their favorite
character customizing your player card
with character portraits and familiar
catchphrases is another avenue to
express your love it's cute and
light-hearted magnified by the adorable
batch of emotes that often take the edge
off exhilarating fights and thankfully
jumping into matches works seamlessly
after hundreds of rounds online both in
the casual Lobby and ranked matchmaking
we can say that the netcode is solid and
latency is a non-issue with a decent
connection players that want a more
competitive environment should be happy
to know that we have little trouble
finding a fair fight in ranked
matchmaking in both victory and defeat
memorable moments abound although it can
be frustrating I'm always taking note of
how high-level players are getting the
better of me
I'll also never forget making a comeback
from being down a teammate activating
resonance blaze and perfectly timing
both cheese power charge and godhand
while my opponent was a mid tag to take
them both out in one hit
[Music]
whether practicing in single-player or
competing against tough opponents online
cross tag battle is an absolute joy with
a surplus of possibilities within its
diverse roster and versatile fighting
system even with all the ridiculousness
of the overarching plot I reveled in the
charm of my favorite characters and
embrace the many moments of fanservice
it's a masterful unification of styles
and mechanics with four different
universes that compels you to dig deeper
and dedicate the time to getting the
most out of the beloved members of this
cast
[Music]